usually i tell you about something or
someone i'm obsessed with at this point
in the show
um well today it's my band who's
obsessed their obsession has taken many
forms
lifeguard knight rider that's right
german icon
everybody's known globally as one name
people the hoff give it up for david
[Applause]
[Music]
hasselhoff
[Music]
how are you doing i'm i'm doing
fantastic what
who's your audience hello everybody say
hello
i forget how you're so tall literally
every time i'm like
okay it's like being around blake um so
uh who is the biggest fan
in the band jason is the biggest fan
i do remember we were on tour in in
germany i believe berlin and y'all went
to the museum what was that like
oh yeah it was incredible i mean i've
been a fan i mean everybody grew up in
knight rider
and i didn't have the heights but i had
some hair and my first car was a black
ford pro because i couldn't afford the
trans am
but uh i mean i knew him as an actor but
i had no idea his musical
catalog until we were all listening to
songs on the bus one night
and i think it was lester that pulled
out one of his rock songs i was like oh
my gosh he can sing
oh my god then we found out about museum
went there and while we were there
they had all these signs that he was
part of the fall of the berlin wall
thought it was a joke went home and
looked it up and it's real like he
played a huge part in that so just keeps
on going so i'm the fan wait so what
yeah is that why the museum is in berlin
the museum is in berlin because i sang
to a million people
on new year's eve and i say i've been
looking for
freedom and and in east germany which
wasn't free at that point
that's all they knew and they knew that
that i was the guy from knight rider who
sang about freedom
so i went and sang above a million
people from east and west germany
and that's why i became famous in in
germany
and then i um i've been going back and
selling a few records and and then they
ended up making a museum about me i know
but that's going to be a crazy moment
you're standing in the center of people
that literally cannot cr
cross the energy of that and all of them
singing the same song
that must have been really powerful it
was unbelievable because i went behind
the wall with a special
that national geographic did and i i
went back and i met
people who escaped and they and i said
how do you know me and then
i've been looking for freedom oh my god
and they couldn't sing the same the next
line because they were taught
russian instead of english in school
yeah
yeah and every it was really tough music
is powerful
it was really tough i do love that music
is powerful it can unite people
yeah i do i believe in that it sounds
cheesy i really do truly believe that um
so wait do you have something planned
with my band today i heard that you did
and i'm very excited
yeah you're missing something in the
show and i think that uh
a theme song you don't have a theme song
oh i don't ever think because we have
worked
up a few theme songs for you all right
can i hear you want to tell me about one
maybe sing one or i don't know
let's just sing it let's sing it okay
let's do it
you have not given me permission to use
these as my thing i'm just saying
because i love it i'm excited
it's time time to watch some gallery
kelly on the deli it's the kelly
clarkson show
you talk about that annie yeah all right
all right
i liked it i felt the vibe i liked it
i love it i have a feeling i'm gonna
want all of them
it's for sale i'm gonna literally have i
want all of them to like
for different people that call because i
feel like you have a few and i want all
of them
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever